résultat analyse en bourgogne franche
comté votre soirée spéciale continuons
ce premier tour des régionales sur
france 3 en bourgogne et franche comté
avec elle des invités qui nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau en direct
bonsoir michel deniau bon choix pour la
liste conduite par marie guite dufay
vous êtes le chef de file pour le
département de la côte d'or à vos côtés
lan pélissard bonsoir soit vous
représentez la liste lr udi conduite par
françois sauvadet et vous êtes la chef
du file pour le département du jura est
avec vous edouard qu'à 20 pour le front
national bonsoir bonsoir la liste de
sophie montel et chef du film pour la
côte d'or pour le front national
des résultats un premier résultat
définitif ils concernent le département
de la haute saône au dos oui la haute
saône où le front national arrive en
tête avec 37,35 % des voix loin devant
la liste du parti socialiste prg de
marie-guite dufay 23 88% des voix en 3e
position c'est la liste de françois
sauvadet a l'air udi avec 20 89% ensuite
de vous la france de maxime chievo 4,76
% la liste de nathalie vermorel pcf et
parti de gauche mrc 3 26%
la liste ensuite d'europe écologie les
verts conduite par cécile prud'hommes à
3%
la liste de christophe grudler du modem
2 44%
la wii avec julien gonzalez 5 93%
lutte ouvrière de claire rocher 1,64 %
enfin la liste de l'upper conduite par
charles henri gallois 0 86% et on
rappelle arnaud peut-être les
estimations pour la bourgogne franche
comté ou front national arrive en tête
également par autres sur france 3 point
fr le fn donc en tête pour la bourgogne
franche comté avec 32% des voix pour ce
premier tour le fn devant la liste
conduite par françois sauvadet l'érudit
avec 24,2 d'arrière marie-guite dufay la
liste du ps avec 21,7 % suivent en
dedans
ensuite après ce trio de tête donc
debout à la france avec autour des 5 %
peut-être un tout petit peu plus simple
lors de cette dernière estimation
affinée devant cécile prud'hommes pour
europe ecologie les verts à 4%
ensuite nous avons nathalie vermorel le
front de gauche à 4,28 donc les deux
listes seraient quasiment à égalité et
nous terminons ce tour d'horizon avec
3,4 pour cent pour le modem devant la
liste à eux y à l'alliance écologiste
indépendante de julien gonzalez lutte
ouvrière à un peu plus d'un pour cent et
d'araignées
c'est charles rielle loi pour l'union
populaire républicaine avec à peine 1 %
et nous partons direction besançon le
kursaal le kursaal ou stéphanie
bourgeois nous attend et peu d'ambiance
ce soir stéphanie et oui nous sommes
toujours oh oui mais l'ambiance elle
n'était pas du tout rendez vous ce soir
ce qui n'est tout à l'heure car un
soupçons se confirment ces élections
feront date dans l'histoire de besançon
et du kursaal d'abord parce qu'elles
sont une première certes vous l'avez dit
ensuite parce que je vous le disais à
l'instant donc l'ambiance n'a jamais été
au rendez-vous cette salle à eau au
mieux de la soirée a compté une
cinquantaine de personnes seulement
c'est du jamais vu comme le vous
confirmerait toutes les personnes qui
ont pris la peine d'assister à la
lecture des résultats et puis bien sûr
elles sont une première de par leurs
résultats marie-guite dufay donné
troisième du tiercé de tête si l'on en
croit les estimations est arrivés ici
peu avant 20h une courte apparition où
elle s'est félicitée de la bonne tenue
de sa liste puisque elle vire largement
en tête sur les 67 bureaux aux bisontins
avec un score de 34,60 2% sur les soins
sur l'ensemble des 67 bureaux dépouillés
elle en a profité pour saluer
la réputation de ville de gauche de
besançon ancienne capitale régionale de
la franche comté
elle s'est ouvertement inquiété du fait
que le front national puisse dépasser la
barre des 20% et de fait donc la liste
de sophie montel une pointe à 21,37 %
des suffrages exprimés sur les 67 pire
aux bisontins donc quelques timides
huées ont salué l'annoncé des résultats
de sa fille de sophie montel pour
ensuite finalement enfin le kursaal
s'est ensuite plongé dans un dans un
silence assez indifférent chacun
préférant tenter d'analyser c'est
désormais cette nouvelle donne régionale
inédite personnes stéphanie une réaction
michel neugnot justement dans les rangs
du parti socialiste comment vous vivez
cette soirée cette soirée déjà ou n'est
pas encore aux termes du régime la
finale c'est une soirée où on constate
que le front national arrive en tête
tout combat de marie du fait et l'appel
à la mobilisation est fait pour
effectivement l'ensemble des forces de
gauche rassemblée soit aux capacités de
bahts deuxième tour le front national et
l'heure est grave
il s'agit pour nous de certaines valeurs
de la république qui ont été développées
pendant toute la campagne des valeurs de
solidarité
le slogan même de la campagne doit en
effet pour vivre ensemble c'est ce que
l'on porte c'est ce que l'on porte ce qu
on a porté pendant tout le début de
campagne jusqu'au premier tour c'est ce
que l'on va amplifier au deuxième tour
on se fait derrière françois sauvadet
dans les premières estimations 0 -
d'amélie dans les estimations actuelles
l'écart est un peu en train de se
creuser est ce que c'est le poignet
point un peu peut faire une différence
attendons le résultat c'est tellement
aléatoire la façon dont les résultats
tombent
ce sont souvent les grandes villes qui
ne sont plus favorables qui arrive
attendons de voir le classement final
mais ce que l'on sait c'est que la
totalité des voix de gauche permet de
maintenir cette région à gauche et
d'éviter la victoire du front national
ce qui n'est pas le cas forcément quand
on totalise
le camp d'en face après on va voir
affiner tout se pose aussi la
problématique de nos partenaires avec
lequel nous souhaitons travailler encore
faut-il que techniquement il dépasser 5%
donc nous attend que j'ai dans mon goût
ça ça aurait été mieux s'il avait passé
les 5 % vous aviez pu construire une
liste commune
honnêtement nous avons tout fait pour
rassembler rassembler déjà cinq partis
et groupes de gauche au premier tour
et puis ensuite nous avons fait en sorte
de travailler à ce rassemblement dans
les derniers jours pour qu'effectivement
on soit en capacité de représenter
ensemble toute la gauche et nous verrons
les résultats mais force est de
constater qu'il n'ya que la gauche unie
qui peut empêcher cette région de passer
au front national on va demander ce
qu'en pense à votre voisine hélène
pélissard donc vous êtes j'allais dire
ump
les républicains vous êtes conseillère
régionale sortante du jura le front
national est en tête devant la liste
socialiste dans le département de haute
saône mais aussi dans le territoire de
belfort qui est aujourd'hui est un fief
de votre camp la liste de françois
sauvadet arrivent troisièmes dans ces
deux départements
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché écoutez
d'abord moi je voudrais remercier les
électeurs qui nous ont porté les
suffrages et plus que vous ne croyez
monsieur neugnot nous reviendrons dessus
tout à l'heure et vie vous dire que oui
le front national est en tête vous
l'aviez prévu c'est le cas dans la
grande région le front national est
devant alors pourquoi je crois qu'il
faut aussi se poser quelques questions
il est en tête d'abord les attentats et
le contexte d'insécurité que nous
connaissons a certainement joué et peser
fortement sur ce scrutin
mais il ya aussi il faut bien le dire
les résultats du gouvernement moi j'ai
les échos là avec moi chez les échos de
ce week-end dans lequel le premier
titres et deux records pour la france le
chômage
le chômage qui a encore augmenté et le
taux de prélèvement des impôts donc
habituellement
à profiter à l'opposition parlementaire
ce type de situation oui mais si vous
voulez je pense que là on est dans une
situation terriblement dramatique pour
notre pays est aujourd'hui c'est la
parole même du chef de l'état et la
parole publique qui est en cause puisque
le président de la république nous
promet la baisse du chômage depuis deux
ans manuel valls nous a dit qu'on allait
baisser les prélèvements obligatoires
rien ne se passe et les français perdent
véritablement confiance
et puis je crois qu'il faut dire aussi
que les territoires ruraux sont
particulièrement inquiet aujourd'hui du
démantèlement des services publics de
l'éloignement des centres de décision et
que tout ceci pèse fort et qu'il ya une
inquiétude qui ce qui se révèle avec ce
vote front national ne calera avoir
nationalisé la campagne en début de
campagne puis l'avoir régionalisés après
les attentats parce que le
le président de la république remonter
dans l'est dans les sondages maintenant
vous souhaitez renationaliser à nouveau
c'est ça dont je souhaite simplement
faire un point parce que je pense que il
est important de le dire
et c'est vrai le front national en
france partout donc on est bien obligé
d'avoir un contexte national le front
national dans tout l'hexagone étant très
haute position mais pour ce qui est de
notre région
moi je vois une chose monsieur neugnot
c'est que nous sommes en tête l'écart
d'ailleurs est en train de se creuser
puisque les derniers résultats sont le
prouver que nous serions à 24,2 et que
vous baissez à 21,7
après à les résultats de besançon nous
nous attendons j'attends assez
sereinement voyez-vous monsieur monsieur
neugnot
donc nous sommes la liste qui à la
dynamique avec nous et bien évidemment
nous souhaitons dire à tous les
électeurs que la seule alternative au
front national aujourd'hui c'est la
liste de françois sauvadet
le front national est à côté de vous
vous nous disiez avant le début de cette
deuxième tranche de la soirée que vous
ne vous attendiez pas forcément un
résultat aussi élevé en bourgogne
franchement je m'attendais pas à un
résultat aussi votre en soit aussi bas
pardon de françois sauvadet surtout en
côte d'or
c'est quand même son fief il est
président du conseil général
on voit que son score est très bas alors
au niveau de la grande région bourgogne
franche comté on voit un score très
proche finalement deux du ps et de des
républicains même si ça se creuse un
petit peu leur score est quand même très
proche
le score du front national est bien plus
élevée à 8 points à peu près de la liste
les républicains et lui dis donc on voit
quand même une dynamique
j'entends parler mais mes adversaires je
pense que la dynamique on peut le dire
et du côté de la liste de sophie montel
et du côté du front national
incontestablement avec quelle reports de
voix avec quelles réserves
écoutez il peut y avoir des réserves des
lecteurs qui sont qui n'ont pas
forcément envie de voter pour monsieur
sauvadet
j'avais écouté le dernier débat que vous
aviez fait avant le premier tour où
monsieur sauvadet mettre un petit peu de
côté l'ump pour dire qu'il n'était que
pour lui dit je crois que certains
électeurs de l'ump seront
particulièrement déçu et derrière une
partie d'entre eux l'ont certainement
montré ce soir maxime thibeault
on espère avoir sur ce plateau plus tard
dans la soirée probablement dans la
dernière tranche pour l'instant crédité
de plus de cinq points
ça veut dire qu'il peut fusionner avec
une liste on a eu un débat tout à
l'heure souverainiste de qui était-il le
plus proche de qui quel est votre point
de vue là dessus mais on demandera à
votre voisine moi j'ai déjà rencontré
maxime thiébaut sur les plateaux de télé
alors je ne sais pas s'il est proche de
nous mais en tout cas je pense qu'il est
très éloignée de monsieur sauvadet
donc je vois pas très bien ce qui
pourrait faire avec monsieur sauvadet et
j'ai du mal à imaginer une fusion de
leurs listes étant donné leurs
différences idéologiques
est-ce que nous à ça je peux pas vous
dire ça sera plutôt à ce film on telle
qu'il faudra poser la question où je ne
crois pas le front national a toujours
voulu créer un vent un grand
rassemblement sans faire des
arrangements de partie au deuxième tour
qui trompe l'élection finalement donc
qui trompe les électeurs hélène
pélissard
écoutez moi je connais moins bien que
arnaud danjean qui était tout à l'heure
sur ce plateau
il le connaît bien il est dansant dans
le même département
maxime thibeault ce que ce que je peux
dire c'est que c'est un vrai républicain
et la formation politique républicain
madame tient à rappeler sur ce plateau
donc debout la république s'il avait
voulu partir au front national ils
seraient déjà partis au front national
donc ils sont dans le bloc républicain
et bien évidemment nous parlons avec
avec lui nous parlons avec eux et je
suis bien persuadé qu'ils aient poudre
ont elles mêmes projets pour la région
que nous on pensait que 32 % des
électeurs de la bourgogne franche comté
sont anti républicain en votant pour le
front national vous poser une question
très sincèrement moi vous savez je viens
de dire je viens de dire monsieur que
pour moi les électeurs qui ont voté pour
vous montrer leur grande inquiétude
ils ont montré leur écriture je crois
pas quand on est premier à une élection
on montre une adhésion
il n'y a pas d'adhésion au front
national de 35 % de la population
française ça j'en suis bien persuadé 10
pour marine le pen quand elle fait plus
de 40 % ni pour marion maréchal-le pen
quand elle fait 42% vous
6 heures vous vous jouer sur la peur
effectivement il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes dans notre pays moi j'ai
été très marqué par votre profession
fois d'ailleurs je l' ai je l'air à
apporter ici vous dit marine le pen et
madame montel disent quelque chose qui
m'a mais révolté c'est une imposture
incroyable vous dites nous allons lancer
nous allons instaurer une politique de
tolérance zéro et créer une police
régionale des transports
on n'a pas le droit quand on est honnête
d'écrire des choses pareilles pourquoi
mais je vais vous expliquer c'est très
très facile il y à deux niveaux de
responsabilité dans notre pays et qui
peuvent avoir une police c'est l'état
bien évidemment police nationale pouvoir
régalien de l'état et il y a
éventuellement les communes puisque le
maire est officier de police judiciaire
il peut avoir et il peut avoir une
police qu'il commande
mais on n'a jamais vu un président de
région
avoir une police à sa main ça n'existe
pas déjà été testé d'ailleurs les
résultants et être tout à fait probant
donc je vois pas pourquoi ce serait pas
possible
il n'y a pas une police avec aider c'est
tout à fait possible de mettre en place
nous poursuivrons le débat sur ce sujet
sur d'autres pour l'instant à tour sur
les réseaux sociaux elle avec des
réactions sur twitter premières
réactions notamment de françois sauvadet
qui cède un sens ce moment même à ses
militants dans son qg oui ce soir je
suis inquiet pour l'avenir de ma région
et c'est pour cela que nous allons nous
mobiliser à fond durant cette semaine
merci beaucoup et les âges vous propose
à présent d'écouter une réaction la
réaction de claire rocher qui est tête
de liste pour lutte ouvrière je vous
propose de revoir le résultat des
estimations justement de lutte ouvrière
et qui atteindrait donc 1,4 pour cent
des suffrages on est tout
on écoute pardon tout de suite sa
réaction la droite a mené l'ensemble de
sa campagne sur le terrain du front
national et le parti socialiste au
gouvernement
oui a mis en place un état d'urgence qui
lui permet de muscler les mouvements
sociaux et toute contestation sur sa
gauche
donc effectivement cette évolution elle
est une évolution de l'ensemble de la
société
votre liste arrive en queue de peloton
une consigne de vote pour le second tour
ah oui moi je déjà je tiens à remercier
les électeurs qui ont voté pour la liste
lutte ouvrière pour faire entendre le
camp des travailleurs
ça représente près de 12000 personnes
sur la région bourgogne franche comté et
c'est loin d'être négligeable parce que
ce sont des gens qui affirme que
l'ajustement l'avenir il n'est pas pour
la classe ouvrière dans les urnes
qu'elle n'avait pas à espérer quoi que
ce soit de ces élections et donc il n'y
a pas à désespérer du résultat du tout
et qu au contraire sa force elle est
entière sa force ce sont les mouvements
sociaux c'est le rapport de force dans
la société et moi au deuxième tour
j'invite les travailleurs conscients a
refusé de choisir quelle sera la clique
de la bourgeoisie qui au gouvernement ou
dans les régions prendra les mesures
contre les classes populaires parce que
c'est ce qui nous attend est donc à
affirmer à nouveau leur camp en veut
tant avec pourquoi pas un bulletin lutte
ouvrière mais en tout cas certainement
pas à choisir entre les partis en lice
claire rocher pour lutte ouvrière
charles gallois présents réaction pour
l'union populaire républicaine
le parti obtient 0 9% dans notre
estimation arif dernier des dix listes
en lice pour la bourgogne franche comté
charles-henri gallois malgré tout
satisfait de son score écouter les
élections européennes nous avions fait 0
3% des voix douce il faut bien
comprendre c'est une multiplication par
trois des nôtres score dans un contexte
encore une fois de silence des grands
médias absolument totale et quand on
parle de ce scrutin là on ne peut pas
faire l'impasse sur l'abstention qui est
encore le premier parti de france et la
responsabilité des médias qui donne 80 %
du temps de parole au pse républicain ou
du fn alors que des sondages récents ont
montré que 75 % des français ne voulait
plus de ses parts il a donc évidemment
la part des médias est écrasante puisque
si les gens de votre père c'est parce
qu'une nouvelle pauvreté huppert c'est
parce qu'il ne nous connaissent pas et
peut-être 2 % des français qui lui
connaissent on fait zéro
pour cent des voix ce qui est un taux de
conversion assez remarquable de
charleroi gallois pour lui père
précisions sur la mise en accusation ou
des médias il y à des règles qui
existent qui sont validées par le cs est
donc que chaque partie s'est exprimé
notamment sur france 3 avec la règle
d'équité qui vaut pour ce scrutin
direction nevers où guillaume maillard
nous attend chef de file pendant la
nièvre pour la liste elle est rude et
conduite par françois sauvadet guillaume
mayer qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
selon vous pour ce score atteint par la
liste de françois sauvadet me rappelle
un peu plus de 24 % des voix au premier
tour
bonsoir écouter avant de dire ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné ça s'inquiéter de façon
inquiétante sur la montée du fn ne la
montée du fn est devenu maintenant une
habitude et on s'aperçoit que il ya un
vote de colère mais il ya bien un vote
d'adhésion qui doit nous alerter tous
les hommes politiques républicains à
raisonner différemment pour les années à
venir
maintenant concernant ce score du front
national
on voit que c'est un score qui
sanctionne lourdement le parti
socialiste qui sanctionne lourdement le
gouvernement le chômage augmente les
pouvoirs d'achat d'aider des français
continuent à chuter
on voit que le gouvernement est
largement sanctionné et on voit que la
liste de françois sauvadet que je mène
dans la nièvre arrive de façon globale
au niveau de la région en deuxième
position avec une indifférence par
rapport au parti socialiste donc je
reste confiant sur la dynamique que nous
avons avec françois sauvadet avec
l'équipe autour d'un projet la région
grand qui reste à mon sens plus que je
mets le projet de l'avenir
guillaume aia comment vous voyez cette
cet entre deux tours de votre point de
vue vers qui devez vous allez pour pour
espérer l'emporter
écoutez l'entre-deux tours est clair
nous avons une liste solides nous avons
un projet solide nous avons un leader
françois sauvadet qui connaît bien notre
territoire nous n'allons pas aller dans
de la gesticulation mais entend parler
dans la tambouille si je puis dire nous
allons aller vers un deuxième tour où
nous allons essayer de faire bloc
d'appeler à la mobilisation d'appeler à
tous les citoyens pour pouvoir donner un
vrai projet le projet socialiste c'est
le projet qu'on a connus depuis onze ans
je pense que les bourguignons les doigts
contraintes de votre union délit il n'y
a pas de fusion des listes pas
d'alliance éventuellement on parle
depuis tout à l'heure de maxime thiébaut
quel est votre point de vue là dessus
écoutez maxime thiébaut quelqu'un de
respectable qui a fait un score qui lui
permet effectivement de ce2 de se
maintenir dans le jeu au moment où je
vous parle au nom on n'envisage
aucunement une une fusion en tout cas
c'est le message que l'on veut passer à
tous l'espèrent les téléspectateurs
pardon c'est noté merci guillaume mayer
en direct de la préfecture de nevers des
résultats définitifs nous arrive celui
du département de l'yonne en bourgogne
où la liste de sophie montel pour le
front national arrive largement en tête
avec plus de 36 % des suffrages devant
la liste de françois sauvadet lr udi
22,4 var guide du feu le ps 18,4
derrière la liste de maxime thibeault
debout la france nous l'évoquions un peu
plus de 6% 5% au-dessus des 5% pour les
stades de nathalie vermorel pour le
front de gauche europe écologie les
verts est à 4,2 christophe grudler pour
le modem atteint les 3 % la liste de
julien gonzalez alliance écologiste
indépendante 2,1 et puis laisse donc de
claire rocher lutte ouvrière 1,4 et
charles-henri gallois pour l'upm est à 1
% dans le département de l'yonne narre
dans le territoire de belfort à présent
le parti le front national de sophie
montel arrive là
je montais 34,76 % des suffrages devant
marie-guite dufay parti socialiste 20
72% en troisième position la liste elle
est rude et y de françois sauvadet avec
18 points 76 % des suffrages en 4e le
modem christophe grudler christophe
couderc liés dans le territoire de
belfort avec 7,99 % des voix derrière
lui nathalie et vers noël avec
alternative à gauche 4 64% des voix
debout la france maxime chievo 4 15%
cécile prud'hommes d'europe écologie les
verts 4,04 pour son julien gonzalez et
la wii devient 11% lutte ouvrière avec
claire rocher 1 88%
enfin charles ankri gallois et l'upm
recueil 0,95 % des suffrages vous
propose à présent d'aller du côté de
besançon ont rejoint catherine aime
syrie et ses invités et oui et le
plateau que j'ai autour de moi est
extrêmement caractéristiques de la
gauche en france
condom gones franche-comté puisque j'ai
trois conseillers régionaux de gauche
sur ce plateau et tous les trois ou fait
partie de liste totalement différente
tout d'abord denis solaire pour le parti
socialiste il est vice président du
conseil régional sortant
il était chargé des questions
économiques il était même le premier
vice président face à lui brigitte
monnet qui était que le gist donc du
jura et puis alain le tailleur qui est
du territoire de belfort
il était sur la liste l'alternative à
gauche de nathalie vermorel
et il est aux mrc le mouvement
républicain et citoyen alors on va
commencer avec vous denis sommer est ce
que vous regrettez justement que la
gauche soit partie en ordre dispersé
pour ces élections
écoutez les résultats sont là quelque
part à rien
il ya un gâchis parce que certains nos
partenaires ne seront plus élu à la
région alors que nous avons géré on sent
pas dans un monde à même le mois
précédent avec avec raymond forni je
crois que nous l'avons bien fait même si
il peut y avoir bien évidemment entre
nous quelques sacs quelques désaccords
nous sommes bien évidemment différent
ceci étant nous avons toujours su
dépasser ses désaccords construire des
compromis intelligent et gérer
efficacement la vous n'avez pas réussi à
vous entendre vous avez par marie-guite
dufay je crois tendu la main
bon chacun dans sa logique
on va demander si ce n'est qu'elle et
son sentiment ce soir parce que a priori
donc europe ecologie les verts donc la
liste conduite par cécile prud'hommes ne
dépasse pas la barre des 5 % à
susceptible donc de fusil qui donne un
score susceptibles de fusionner avec la
liste de marie-guite dufay
vous le regrettez ça veut dire que il y
aura plus du coc logist au conseil
régional de franche comté et ce quel que
soit le vainqueur de dimanche prochain
alors le choix qui avait été fait c'est
le choix des adhérents europe ecologie
les verts et s'étaient prononcés à plus
de 80% pour nous a déposés dans des
jarres du sidère c'était une volonté
dans un contexte
je dirais de coop 21 aussi d'avancer
beaucoup plus vite sur sur ce que
portent les écologistes
là c'est raté alors là les résultats ne
sont pas là ça c'est une évidence mais
tout de même le contexte est tout à fait
particulier gérer que c'est raté pour
quasiment tous les partis sauf le front
national sauf le front national donc on
peut être particulièrement d'ailleurs
étonné que ce qui que les attentats et
bien sûr et pris le dessus à ce point là
alors qu'il y a encore un autre danger
que celui de réchauffement climatique et
qui fait et peut être injecté loin dans
le vivant celui là il est peut-être un
petit peu plus loin il dans le temps et
géographiquement mais est ce que vous
pensez vous pensez que vous avez dit
victime de ce qu'on appelle le vote
utile
je ne fais pas à cette heure si je n'ai
pas une analyse assez fine des résultats
je ne pense pas qu'on était victime du
vote utile je crois qu'on était victime
d'un d'événements nationaux qui ont
complètement déstabilisé des mollahs qui
ont changé ils y ont changé la donne
alain le tailleur donc vous c'était la
liste l'alternative à gauche qui
visiblement n'a pas pris à l'heure où
l'on parle elle ne dépasse pas la barre
des 5 % alors victime du vote utile ou
d'autres choses déjà un premier élément
pour répondre à denis robert qui a
évoqué le gâchis si nous n'étions plus
en ré élu à la région je crois que les
sorbets regrettez vous ne soyez pas les
uns et les autres à ses côtés au cas où
il ya une victoire de marie-guite dufay
pour autant quand on fait de la
politique c'est d'abord pour défendre
des idées des convictions je pense que
ce soit les verts ou la mouvance que je
représente un républicaine et sociale
on a démontré dans plusieurs élections
depuis des années que la le mandat
n'était pas le but ultime de la vie
politique
mais c'était d'abord de défendre des
valeurs et les valeurs de la gauche que
la gauche a perdu
pour ce qui me concerne on peut regarder
tous les résultats c'est un mauvais
résultat quand même
la gauche je crois que il faut
l'entendre c'est aussi un mauvais
résultat d'ailleurs pour la droite
républicaine
je pense que si nous ne revenons pas
quand même à des fondamentaux qui sont
celles de la liberté l'égalité de la
fraternité mais un carnet réellement pas
simplement clamé au moment d'un
événement dramatique qui touche la
france mais qui est incarnée dans les
politiques économiques dans les
politiques sociales
si nous ne revenons pas là dessus les
résultats seront identiques d'élection
en élection facile à vous pour ces
valeurs vous ne pourrez pas les porter
dans le prochain mandat au conseil en
vue là c'est un regret il ya tellement
de manières de porter ce type de voleur
et faut-il être élu pour léa je vais
revenir sur un débat politique puisque
nous sommes ici sur un débat politique
ils ont peut pas oublier la politique du
gouvernement actuel
hollande valls la politique d'austérité
qui qui finalement conduit au résultat
qu'on constate heures cela dénis sa mère
on comprend pourquoi vous n'avez pas
fait listes communes
oui encore que on a fait liste commune
par par le passé et ça a bien fonctionné
encore une fois moi je comprends encore
une fois on est différent mais c'est pas
un drame des défis que d'être différent
on peut discuter ensemble on peut
débattre on peut trouver des compromis
on peut s'enrichir aussi les c'est
l'heure de la messe que c'est l'heure du
débat quand le front national est aussi
haut dans notre région mais la question
qui est posée aujourd'hui alain disait
il faut qu défendre des valeurs
mais voilà on y est là maintenant le
front national est à la porte du conseil
régional je pense que ça serait
dramatique pour notre grande région
je rappelle que la région c'est un
milliard trois de budget qu'on va
traiter des questions de formation de
développement économique de culture etc
de la gestion des lycées et est-ce qu'on
peut confier ça à l'extrême droite c'est
un vrai sujet vous savez là la situation
politique qu'on est en train de vivre
on l'a vécu il ya quelques mois dans le
nord franche comté dans la législative
partielle ou frédéric barbier était
candidat on s'est retrouvé quasiment
dans cet élan c'était le siège
initialement détenue par pierre parce
que je joue messieurs barbier et madame
ont-elles ont été opposés au deuxième
tour monsieur barbier
on l'a emporté 2 800 voix ils l'ont
emporté de peu mais qu'est ce qui a
permis qu'est ce qui a permis que
frédéric barbier l'emportent
c'est l'ensemble de la gauche l'ensemble
des républicains se sont rassemblés
autour de 51 system
si on savait qu'on démarre dur et je
pense que les résultats que nous avons
aujourd'hui nous permettent d'envisager
un succès dimanche prochain à condition
que l'ensemble de la gauche mobilise
alors brigitte monnet vous allez appeler
à voter marie-guite dufay ou pas alors
je soulève quand même revenir à la
question précédente
je crois qu'on paie aussi aujourd'hui
sur des élections régionales des
politiques nationales est tous les
renoncements de la gauche quand même
quand on voit la loi maquereau et le
libéralisme que que ça entraîne
aujourd'hui je pense qu'une bonne partie
de la population ne se reconnaissent pas
dans ces politiques là et ne voit pas la
diffuse ne voit plus la différence
vendredi ce qui est une politique de
droite et une politique de l'offre qui
nous restent relativement peu de temps
alors qu'est ce que nous allons oui ou
non soutient ma nous allons alors ce que
j'aimerais bien entendre aussi alain de
taille en ce jeu là où nous appelons
bien évidemment à contrer l'extrême
droite et à contrer la droite
donc ça veut dire votez marie-guite
dufay c'est moi qui finit la phrase que
vous la laissez pas vous l'avez en tout
cas nous notre positionnement
aujourd'hui c'est à dire on fait tout
pour garder une région solidaire
donc on forcément on vous appeler à
voter marie-guite dufay sans le dire
alain le tailleur pour le mrc la liste
alternative à gauche appellent à voter
marie-guite dufay dimanche prochain
budget paru j'ai pas eu le temps en fait
de discuter avec avec mes amis dont j'ai
donné un avis personnel ou très
clairement je m'inscris dans la gauche
républicaine et sociale et de ce point
de vue là mon vote sera celui de
marie-guite dufay au soir du fleuve dans
la journée que ça va être la position de
votre liste a priori
à priori oui très bien merci madame
merci messieurs merci catherine
sur ce qui est d'être dit il à melay
mais un petit mot qu'il faut comprendre
que quoi qu'il arrive quel que soit le
résultat il ya une page qui va se
tourner dans le nouveau conseil régional
de bourgogne franche comté on se
souvient que lors du nouveau mode de
scrutin l'élection de 2004 c'était la
gauche plurielle on va dire qui était
rentré avec des partenaires europe
écologie parti communiste il y avait eu
des accords d'entre deux tours en 2010
ce qui avait conduit les communistes et
europe écologie est représenté au
conseil régional
on a bien compris que si les résultats
se confirment
si la gauche l'emportait ce qu'est
vraiment pas qui on le redit il ya une
espèce de partage en trois tiers des
trois blocs aujourd'hui qui nous permet
pas d'être sûr de quoi que ce soit dans
ce cas là de toute façon l'a bien
compris ces deux partis ne siégeront
plus ce sera une grande nouveauté au
conseil régional
un petit mot peut-être reza sur les
réseaux sociaux oui de réaction de
truites le premier ce sont ces clichés
de julien hakkar qui est donc lui le
candidat frontiste en franche comté dans
le doubs où vous voyez la joie des
militants d'extrême droite
et puis ce deuxième tweet de notre
consoeur florence poli du jsl qui
annonce des sports historiques du fn à
montceau les mines le fn recueille 29%
des voix c'est cinq points de plus que
la liste de marie-guite dufay cela
confirme les à derniers résultats des
municipales dans cette ville en 2014 où
la gauche perdu lors des municipales des
résultats définitifs nous arrive pour
par département avec celui du doubs
d'abord regarder ils vont s'inscrire sur
votre écran résultats définitifs pour ce
département avec le front national et
sophie montel en tête avec près de 32%
des suffrages devant marie-guite dufay à
26% françois sauvadet 22% on continue à
la suite de ces résultats avec debout la
france un peu plus de 4% la liste europe
écologie les verts autour de 4% suivie
par la liste de
vim ce n'était rien de plus de 3% ont
continué les découvrons ensemble
ah bah voilà en gros format c'est
parfait pour cent l'alliance écologiste
indépendante de julien gonzalez un peu
plus de 2% lutte ouvrière 1,4 et lui pr2
charles-henri gallois 0,9 pour le
département du doubs le jura est
justement aller avant d'avant le jura je
vous propose quelques ambiances une
petite ambiance justement dans le qg de
sauvadet de françois sauvadet dans le qg
du doubs où on va voir les militants
quelques images avec des militants et
une ambiance a priori a plutôt morose
sont pas des masses images c'est un
sujet regardez en dépit de l'annoncé de
michèle vianès secrétaire départemental
des républicains dans le doute les
militants restent figées ses deuxièmes
places tant sur le plan national que sur
le plan régional n'a rien de fourie qui
ne savent pas la réalité
le fn y savent pas ce que c'est ce soir
le qg de françois sauvadet ne vibre pas
au contraire c'est le temps des
questions et des constats amers
clairement les enjeux régionaux n'ont
pas été respectées il ya un vent de
sanction du gouvernement évidemment mais
nous on n'a pas su être non plus qu'ils
ont il va falloir qu'on se pose la
question en voyant en interne pourquoi
on n'est pas pris au et pourquoi on n'a
pas su présenter aux français une
alternative crédible
une semaine pour comprendre et mobiliser
les forces chez les républicains à leurs
alliés ce ne sera pas de trop d'autant
plus qu'il y a un réservoir de voix
important compte tenu d'une abstention à
49 % pour atteindre le deuxième tour
s'est pas perdu en temps dans le doubs
en tout cas les militants pourront
commencer à jauger leurs forces
mardi à montbéliard françois sauvadet et
tiendra meeting avec patrick genre à
19h30
histoire d'en appeler au rassemblement
des républicains
allez on sait tout de suite analyse sur
les résultats du jura avec le front
national en tête 29,9 pour cent des
suffrages pour la liste de sophie montel
la liste de françois sauvadet riva
derrière 23 3% marie-guite dufay la
liste parti socialiste 23,2 pour sont
des suffrages en quatrième position
debout la france 5 6% nayer alternative
à gauche 5,2 pour cent en europe
ecologie les verts 4,7 pour cent
ensuite nous avons le modem 3,1 pour
cent et christophe grudler alliance
écologiste indépendante 2 25% lutte
ouvrière 1 24% enfin l'upm obtient 1 %
des voix juste une précision n'a
désormais les quatre départements de
franche-comté
sophie montel du front national est en
tête dans chacun de ces départements le
fn confirme son ancrage dans la région
je vous rappelle par exemple que aux
présidentielles à la présidentielle de
2002 jean marie le pen au premier tour
était déjà en tête dans chacun de ces
départements
et puis il me semble qu'il ya aussi un
vote régional françois sauvadet et
troisième dans trois de ces quatre
départements
peut-être que les francs comtois ce soir
ont aussi voté pour des têtes de listes
franc comtoise c'est avant de re
création sur le plateau je propose
d'écouter une réaction à celle de
philippe hervieu c'est une grande
déception bien sûr une grande déception
pour les écologistes on espérait faire
mieux que ça évidemment là pour la
première fois que tu es bien longtemps
plus de vingt ans il y aura pas
d'écologistes
au conseil régional si tenté que les
résultats qu'on a pour l'instant qui
sont très partiel soit confirmée mais on
pensait bien que dans un climat tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
notamment celui de l'état d'urgence
n'était pas forcément le meilleur moment
pour organiser une
l'élection régionale des élections
régionales de manière très sereine
philippe hervieu donc la liste europe
écologie les verts crédités de 4% des
suffrages au premier tour en bourgogne
et franche-comté lilian on n'a pas
encore parlé il ya deuxième parti
écologiste en lice l'a8 julien gonzalez
qui globalement pour l'instant les
estimations est crédité de 2 2% à peu
près on va se souvenir que en 2010
europe ecologie avait raté la barre des
10 et julien gonzalez était déjà là avec
un peu plus de 2 2% déjà à l'époque pour
la bourgogne pardon effectivement en
france voilà il se passe à peu près le
même phénomène cette fois pour la barre
des 5 et europe écologie va probablement
rater la possibilité de fusionner au
deuxième tour sa division michel neugnot
elle vous coûte au premier tour ses
divisions à gauche
je me suis refus mais tout à l'heure sur
ses divisions mais ce que je devrais
dire au point du débat
on n'est pas commentateurs de des
résultats n'est pas journaliste on est
acteur on est acteur pour un deuxième
tour le deuxième tour le choix est clair
marie-guite dufay dès le début de son
entrée en campagne à fixer notre
campagne sur le thème des valeurs sur
les thèmes des valeurs du vivre ensemble
des valeurs de la république et nous
allons continuer sur ce thème moi je
regrette je les dis de ne pas avoir eu
la capacité avec marie du fait à
rassembler toutes les forces de gauche
dès le premier tour mais il faut pour
bien que nous avons cinq partis et
mouvements de gauche qui se rassembler
dans la liste actuelle qui représentent
aussi des écologistes et républicains
des démocrates
donc ce que l'on va faire c'est demander
à tous les démocrates tous les
républicains de comparer les valeurs
portées par chacune des listes et ceci
dès le début nous arrivait de la zone
gouvernement elle va vous alourdir nuit
au crédit est-ce que vous pensez que
l'on peut déguster aussi sonné l'action
du gouvernement
est-ce que vous pensez que l'action du
président de la république des ministres
régaliens dans les situations que nous
voulons vivre nappe est à la paire des
événements est-ce que vous pensez que
françois hollande qui a une
initialement exceptionnel reconnu par
tous des chefs d'état du monde qui va
les recevoir au moment de la coop
est-ce que vous pensez que ce chef
d'état reconnu par la pertinence de ses
choix et bien obligatoirement il est
mauvais quand il s'agit de politique
intérieure et oui madame oui madame et
je vais les salaires de genève le pense
c'est son droit
madame peu l'histoire a le droit de
penser ce qu elle veut j'ai le droit de
dire ce que je veux et ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que le combat pour les
valeurs il a porté par le président de
la république il a porté par christiane
taubira il est porté par manuel valls
il est porté par l'ensemble des
ministres et c'est ce positionnement que
nous avons eu de tout temps dans cette
campagne on n'a jamais eu de débat
national
mais on s'est placé en bourgogne franche
comté avec au fronton de nos
propositions
les valeurs qui sont celles de la gauche
celle de la solidarité celle de
république qui naturellement son encre
et de danse qui sont partagées par
beaucoup de démocrates
est ce que nous disons aujourd'hui nous
sommes les seuls en capacité de battre
le front national si nous savons si nous
savons nous ressent nous rassembler
ça nous avons lu rassemblé revenir avec
adrien vincent c'est le message que nous
voulons porter d'ici le deuxième tout me
fait de nouveau parler du gouvernement
un ancien ministre françois rebsamen le
maire socialiste de dijon a réagi tout à
l'heure et l'appel est lui aussi à
l'union écouter seul aujourd'hui je fais
un constat seuls aujourd'hui la gauche
rassemblée derrière marie-guite dufay
est en situation de faire échec au front
national
échec de françois sauvadet on le voit
qui n'a pas de réserve quasiment qui est
battue 6-1 battu ce soir c'est françois
sauvadet et en même temps j'allais dire
il faut tout faire pour empêcher le
front national de s'emparer de cette
région dans aucune région de france le
fonctionnel n'est capable d'atteindre
les 50% donc 31 % le front national n'a
pas de réserves
nous on peut rassembler la gauche et
c'est un appel que je lance plus
largement que la gauche
tous les républicains il faut tout faire
tout faire pour empêcher le front
national et sa responsable local de
d'emporter la région la semaine
prochaine une réaction edouard avait
toujours un petit peu la même c'est que
le seul programme finalement de monsieur
new représentants du ps c'est autour de
cette table et on vient d'entendre
monsieur rebsamen c'est le même cas
c'est de combattre le front national
mais je crois que aujourd'hui c'est pas
du tout ce que souhaitent les électeurs
et d'ailleurs il le prouve par le score
du front national
c'est pas leurs objectifs leur objectif
d'avoir une autre politique qui mène la
région voilà cette politique je crois
que nous l'incarnons et le ps dans cette
un petit peu de ce couloir à vouloir
absolument battre le front national
c'est un petit peu le cas aussi de lui
et lui des idées des républicains parce
que avec la déroute qui viennent de
subir ce soir je crois que par dont on
parlait justement de l'udf de la déroute
on vient juste de recevoir la réaction
la première réaction de la soirée 2
françois sauvadet tête de lit justement
pour l air d y écouter et notre liste
termine en deuxième position devant
celles du parti socialiste qui était
légitimement sanctionné dans ce contexte
particulier alors que le front national
est en mesure de prendre la région je
mesure la responsabilité qui est la
mienne c'est celle de rassembler pour
éviter le pire donc chacun désormais
placé face à ses responsabilités
les citoyens comme nous mais aussi les
autres formations politiques
il n'y aura de ma part je veux le dire
dès ce soir ni gesticulations ni
combinaison qui serait source de
confusion parce que la confusion elle
conduit à l'inaction c'est précisément
ce que ne veulent plus nos compatriotes
je veux et je souhaite que les choses
changent dans notre région
je suis mieux l'équipe que j'ai
constitué une équipe solide et je n'ai
pas l'intention d'en changer les têtes
de listes des différents partis que nous
accueillerons dans la dernière partie de
cette émission spéciale en bourgogne
franche comté tout à l'heure dans un
quart d'heure sur france 3 un petit mot
peut-être justement il nous reste peu de
temps avant la fin de cette tranche mais
jérémy les lignes
qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir déjà ce
qu'on peut retenir c'est qu'on est dans
une situation absolument inédite dans
ces élections régionales jusqu'à
maintenant au soir du premier tour on
avait une vision assez claire de ce qui
allait se passer
il est difficile de le dire aujourd'hui
d'autant que les estimations elle bouge
on n'a pas encore le chiffre bourgogne
franche comté
on est en plein dans le nouveau
tripartisme c'est à dire qu'il ya
d'évidence trois blocs un bloc de droite
un blog du front national à bloc de
gauche alors les accords seront pas
forcément les mêmes puisque tout le
monde n'est pas en position de rester
mails entre deux tours s'annoncent
extrêmement serrées aujourd'hui la
question s'avère effectivement de savoir
qui a la dynamique l'évidence que nous
ont donné la suite des sondages c'est
que françois sauvadet en bourgogne
n'avait pas cette dynamique marie-guite
dufay l'avait dans les chiffres pour
l'instant le front national bien
évidemment puisque les chiffres on
continue à croire à croître
maintenant on est quand même dans
quelque chose d'extrêmement serré il
faut le redire pendant toute cette
soirée
oui pouvoir réagir là parce que je suis
quand même un peu étonné par ce que
j'entends sur les chiffres suis désolé
les chiffres sont têtus et les sondages
ont donné françois sauvadet en baisse
depuis deux semaines écoutez il était
peut-être en baisse depuis deux semaines
les attentats ont fait que les choses
ont un peu bougé il président la
république comme vous le dites a fait
beaucoup de politique internationale
ce qui n'empêche que ces résultats en
politique nationale monsieur je suis en
train de vous dire que ça ne cache pas
et ça ne gomme pas les mauvais résultats
de politique nationale
mais moi je suis quand même assez
tonique de ce que je viens d'entendre
vous dites monsieur neugnot que vous
avez une dynamique derrière vous vous
êtes troisième alors que vous étiez
premier vice président de la région
bourgogne
madame s'arrête là mot de la fin pour
cette fois ci puisque nous allons
continuer à débattre en un quart d'heure
avec le chef de file des têtes de liste
qui nous rejoindront à nouveau pour
continuer le débat en bourgogne franche
comté débat animé fait davantage de ces
soirées électorales ont rapidement que
le front national à 32% dans
l'estimation en bourgogne franche comté
en tête pour ce premier tour tout de
suite carole gaessler et francis
letellier rendez-vous en bourgogne et en
franche comté dans un quart d'heure à
tout à leur encontre